[Applause]
developing a series for a yearly release
must be a tricky business in the space
of just a few months you need to make
everything look nicer and produce
meaningful gameplay strides with post
2018 Konami zaniel soccer game that
looks and sounds a little too similar to
last year's edition but some excellent
on pitch tweaks are enough to make it
the most satisfying football game ever
made
most noticeable change is a reduction in
the game speed matches play out a slower
more methodical and more realistic pace
crucially however everything feels just
as responsive as before combined with a
number of new animations the slower pace
lends each kick a greater sense of
weight
it also means when you lose the ball it
usually takes longer to get it back
which can frustrate especially when
defending is not improved meaningfully
in a couple of years now
despite PES shifting dino gear is
mechanics still allow you to pull off
some spectacular maneuvers passes feel
more satisfying than ever and are aided
by better positioning of Weidman meaning
more opportunities to pick out players
with pinpoint cross field balls ground
passes are executed with greater variety
meanwhile your players will contextually
change from spraying the ball with the
outside of the boot to curling with the
inside to punting on the toe it will
passings versatility lets you produce
some beautiful football play with
Barcelona and you can actually play like
Barcelona but also means you can lump it
to the big man up top or play at wide
and get crosses in if a particular
situation demands err this is especially
helpful from set pieces which have been
reworked to allow you to pick different
tactics depending on the situation you
can now choose to send your center-backs
forward for long free kicks for example
and you can pick where you want your
players to run to you from corners
direct free kicks have been improved too
and they now feel less stiff and more
intuitive
[Music]
however PES has a major problem its lack
of licenses of the world's major leagues
only the French and Italian leads a
licensed synthase with the Premier
League EFL and the Spanish leagues only
included in make-believe form as is
traditional with Pro Evo teams are
replicated with fake kits and pretend
team names like man blue for Manchester
City London FC for Chelsea an MD white
for Real Madrid while the German league
is not present in any form even the fake
kits are often wildly different to the
real-life versions they're meant to be
imitating thankfully it's relatively
easy to mod in authentic kits on ps4 and
pc though xbox one users are stuck with
the likes of West Glamorgan City a mercy
site blue for good the lack of attention
paid to how its look is reflected in the
game's presentation as a whole while PES
is main rival FIFA replicates the
experience of watching soccer on TV
pretty closely Pro Evo 2018 looks a bit
flat by comparison crowds appear like
cardboard cutouts and signed almost as
fake as they look Peter Drury and Jim
Begg lines all fall stilted commentary
also returns with a cliche ridden
library that contains few new lines and
0 extra excitement these complaints
aren't new to PES 2018 but as FIFA's
presentation continues to improve PES is
poor sights and sounds of put in stark
contrast with every passing year against
Inter this is Peter curry and I'm happy
to inform you that Jim Eglin has joined
me to offer his expertise it's a real
thrill to be here the same is true of
PES is online offering Konami is answer
to FIFA Ultimate Team my club this year
adds 3v3 online co-op play a mode in
which you sacrificed most of the control
in return some laughs with your friends
however PES was frequently unable to
connect enough humor players meaning
often ended up controlling one third of
an otherwise AI control team it's not
quite the fun addition it should be
especially when I was occasionally
subject to some horrible input like when
playing online the offline single-player
masterly make strides in some areas
while remaining infuriating in others
the new menu lair is a welcome change
that makes the mode easier to navigate
but there's still a number of glaring
oddities that need to be addressed youth
teams are still littered with unknown
players whose names were seemingly
assembled by a monkey on a typewriter
for example and transfer budgets are
still criminally low while PSG writes
spending a hundred and fifty million
pounds on a buffet and 200 million on
Neymar in real life this summer I was
restricted to just 50 million in total
with them in person
18 thankfully a couple of neat touches
like customizable training regimes and
release causes employers contracts do
add some depth and the new challenge
mode keeps things interesting with
unexpected scenarios like players
wanting to leave
overall PES 2018 is the proverbial game
of two halves off the field is sorely
lacking online modes and server issues
leave much to be desired and the game's
presentation as a whole is lagging
behind the competition even if the PES
community produces some sterling work
and recreating the unlicensed kits every
year but when you get onto the pitch no
other football game feels as good as
post 2018 the slower pace is a definite
improvement
having tread the line between realism
and fun near perfectly it's just
something about how the players and the
ball move that's just so pleasant to
control every pass header and shot just
feels right and when it clicks and you
score a thunderous strike from the edge
of the area or finish off a slick
passing move or even when you launch an
ugly long ball forward to a grab a last
minute winner as the closest feeling
you'll get to being out there scoring
yourself
[Applause]
he found away from the spot and they
have won it in the most thrilling
fashion
[Applause]
you
[Music]